[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey all you folks with questions welcome
back to the dark horse podcast live
stream
q a number 96.
not all of these people have questions
they are here because they are the sort
of people who are interested in
questions and what might be interesting
questions yes and actually i actually i
take that back i think that you all have
questions i'm quite sure
not all of you have asked those
questions
maybe not all of you have questions of
us
yeah hi
our kitty cat is here
okay we're going to start a cat who if
he shows up more fully on camera you
will see that he had a run-in with
medical destiny and has been shaved in
various places by doctors who needed to
give him medication he looks really
unfortunate yeah he's a patchwork cat
he's all right he's shaved him in like
five different spots i really don't know
why
it's hard to grasp
okay
um
but he's fine he seems to be doing
really well
okay
from the discord this week
i should have asked you this in advance
oh no um
do carbon carbon-based life-forms imply
the existence of carbon cringe
life-forms
um
i i take your point discord people um
yes no that's uh
there was acknowledgement that this was
sort of a
light-hearted question a light-hearted
question yeah
that's cool implies nice nice job but um
yeah what carbon cringe like
it implies let's put it this way yeah
the fact i mean maybe a silicon based
life form is in fact a carbon cringe
life form
whoa
no that's no that's a bridge too far yes
i would say the fact of carbon based
life forms implies the possibility of
carbon cringe life forms but having
encountered many carbon cringe life
forms i don't think we need to depend on
that shaky rung of the logical ladder oh
you see what i'm saying
we've all met them
yeah no just because they appear to
exist um that's outside outside
neighbors doing landscaping
um we're terraforming they're terrible
yes there's there it's there at a
technological frontier in their own
landscape we live on where they think
they are the mushrooms have kicked in
and they are terraforming their own
property
yeah i don't think that requires
mushrooms
uh i've seen people not on mushrooms
terraforming their own property hello no
no at the point oh my god oh boy at the
point you think oh goodness yeah yeah
all right
kitty cat um at the point you think your
property
needs terraforming rather than just
landscaping that may be the mushrooms
that may be the mushrooms indeed okay he
may have
deleted questions i really hope not
this is not going super smoothly yet
okay next question are we done with
carbon based versus carbon cringe yeah
but thank you yeah i like the question
good day doctors and thank you for
everything i have a new obesity
hypothesis you might agree with the
third cause of obesity after low
activity and poor nutrition is climate
control
being 70 degrees fahrenheit in all four
seasons cripples our metabolism by
eliminating our need for involuntary
body temperature regulatory systems yes
totally agree with um i awesome that you
came up with that it's not new to you
but as we used to say to our students
reinventing the wheel is awesome because
the wheel was an incredible invention
and
um just because it doesn't happen to be
new to the universe doesn't mean that
it's not um new uh you know
demonstrating that you were generating
something interesting and i think
absolutely yeah and in fact i've been
playing with this hypothesis for many
years there's an obvious side to it and
what i consider to be a much less
obvious side to it cool so
um
if you are cold
then burning
food calories for heat is a place that
food calories go and if that need is
reduced by the fact that your building
burns fossil fuels
in order to keep you warm then obviously
in the oversimplified equation of
calories in versus calories spent
um
you will have a residual but also that's
the obvious one that's the obvious one
but if you are
too hot
right you would think that that might
actually preserve calories but in fact
the radiation of heat from your system
involves the pumping of blood into
capillary beds near the surface etcetera
um
yeah the
act of thermoregulation in either
direction requires something right
now there are other auxiliary features
of this at least as an endotherm
um
one that i have uh played with is
when
your activity pattern
not only spends calories
but it also dictates the cost of
food calories that are stored on you
that you are walking about with
right so in other words
if you are fat
then every step costs more and so
there is undoubtedly an underlying
system deciding what the sweet spot is
with respect to how much to store and
what it must be monitoring are things
like
what how regular your access to food is
how much you move around and therefore
how much you're spending to carry those
resources around with you and basically
the novelty of our situation has sent
really bad data in there including
probably things like hormonal effects
you know oh absolutely fattened animals
with hormones
and those hormones
trigger your system as well things like
this so
it's not going to be a simple matter
of any one thing but i would say
strong likelihood that climate control
in your environment is playing an
important role and just as
you know if you have a very
simple-minded model of how to get strong
by lifting stuff right like lifting
weights you may think well the more
times you do it the better and it may in
fact be that because building muscle
is
an informational question do you need
more muscle
lifting weight that you're fully capable
of lifting many times may not be that
useful oh well that was tiring okay
right as opposed to not send information
to the system that says your muscle is
inadequate but if you just barely lift
something or even better maybe fail to
lift something then the message is well
actually you need more muscle than
you've got exactly um so spending less
time
at work that is more difficult uh can be
much more effective at least in strength
training and probably there are many
such systems like this yeah and so
the the bottom line is you're dealing
with a complex system that is monitoring
information and we are feeding it
garbage information very noisy
information but if you can figure out
what it's monitoring then hacking your
own system is liable to be much
simpler because it may not be you know
the amount of effort you put into
lifting weights for example it may not
be proportional to how effective it is
it may be the information that they
convey you know if you think about what
your body
understands when you
fail to lift something it doesn't know
that you're not struggling
to find food right and that lifting
things is part of that process and
you're not able to do it and therefore
that's getting in the road of how well
fed you're going to be or something like
that
so yes an informational system to be
sure indeed
um
i'll just ask if we can't we can't
can you predict a few horribly
misleading headlines that we're likely
to see as a result of your latest
appearance on the joe rogan experience
i don't want to do their work for them
i don't want to do their work for them
um
yeah yeah
yeah
uh yes it's a funny question
it's a funny question oh my god we'll
yeah we'll see him or you know
maybe we won't i don't know
i'm sorry it's a it's a funny question
amusing but no we're not doing the work
for anyone like that that's good
um
our
is the opium of the masses
a psychological possum game while
achieving a negative sum game oh
okay it's it's spelled like possum a
psychological positive sum game while
achieving a negative sum game in the
polluting world such that you are happy
with less
well i don't think the screens
render you very happy
they they
it's only very short term it's only
those sort of endocrinological you know
dopamine
it's the dopamine traps yeah that are
there that make you pursue some kind of
happiness or a fix a social fix um
yeah whereas you know the borrowing here
from is it mark's religion being the
opium of the masses i think that was
marx opiate
being yes but
to borrow from this phrase here um
agree or disagree with that sentiment
and i would disagree
um but
religion is al is is
going after a long-term thing so i mean
maybe you think this this might be sort
of a corrective to marx's
misunderstanding of what religion was
perhaps because
in fact
religion does inform your entire life
and
and does go after those longer term
basically meeting making centers yeah or
did
yeah
can yeah could we could also correct
marks just i mean it's a more modern
take but uh
opioids are the opiates the masses i
think
who could argue
yeah
you gave me that
that look where
the thought of divorce briefly
crossed your mind no no no
you got rid of it that's not the look
okay yeah good
that's a relief
uh have you read sir roger scrutin's
dying in time essay any thoughts can't
wait for my copy of your book to arrive
thank you both um i have not but i saw
this and went and looked at it real
quickly actually
not that
this is necessarily useful but zach you
can show my screen briefly it does
appear to be
zack you still there
um
i thought our producer had had left the
building
i thought he was doing drugs no he
didn't no i didn't
um anyway this is the i began i read two
paragraphs of it was all i had time for
um and it looks uh extraordinary and
timely and um definitely worth reading
so i found it for free simple google
search but this happens to be at
nottinghilleditions.com
dying in time an essay by roger skooten
i am intrigued yeah yeah
um so thank you for that recommendation
okay um how about
how about starting an online non-woke
university via zoom there have been
several quality professors who have had
to leave imagine what a great school
that would be in high demand worldwide
shall i deliver the answer sure okay
here's the problem for us
a online is never quite going to cut it
which doesn't mean it's not worth doing
but it means that from the point of view
we had a very unusual
job at evergreen that was for those who
used it to its fullest was
absolutely fantastic where we had
complete freedom to teach what we want
as we wanted to teach it we could
reinvent teaching if we wanted
our students knew us well they took a
class full-time we taught a class
full-time that class could go on for a
full year so everybody was so well-known
to each other that the teaching could be
extremely personal and it could be
multi-dimensional
and i got away with things like never
filing a syllabus so that if a point
went really quickly it didn't have to
take a certain amount of time and if a
point that you thought was going to take
an hour took a week that was okay too
there was there was a lot of flexibility
in
in the teaching and so i'm sure i speak
for you here too going from that level
of freedom even to a regular teaching
job at a college where you're in that
level of relationship as well freedom
and relationship i don't mean it's not
the freedom i mean lots of people took
that freedom and did nothing right there
was a lot of that at evergreen but for
us if you felt like figuring out what
you could do in a teaching environment
and there was nobody
as long as students showed up there was
nobody was going to tell you couldn't
reinvent it right that kind of freedom
if you were if you were the kind of
person who used it and
tried to figure out what was possible in
a classroom
it was an amazing environment and so if
you eliminate that freedom and you
suddenly put us in front of you know a
class of 100 people teaching four
credits at a time it just doesn't sound
at all interesting
and even worse if it becomes a
one-step more remote relationship where
it's large numbers of people over zoom
so is there room for such a thing that
could be valuable to people yes it could
be
better than not but from the point of
view of taking people who've had this
incredible experience where we were
empowered to do things in a classroom
that are almost impossible to do under
any normal circumstances and you say
well how about teach no resume it just
seems like
uh hard to
hard to motivate to make that happen
yeah
and to the extent that it is possible to
do something like that we're kind of
doing it right this is not exactly that
yeah you know it's not it's
this is not
there are elements that are similar you
know i i would be architecting
things such that certain things would
come at certain moments and be
surprising to some people and not to
others and such um if i thought of this
as as curricular right um
but
it is
it it still it requires such a feedback
an active feedback process and and um
and the value in it like the value for
us is so much or for me anyway was so
much in the interactions with the people
and you know frankly learning from the
people as well not you know not just
things that they knew that i didn't or
ways of approaching things that hadn't
occurred to me or
were effective when i wouldn't have
thought they would have been um but
actually you know their feedback in
terms of like oh this thing that i
thought was really cool is falling flat
it's because no one's had their coffee
yet or because i was wrong and this
thing that i thought i was doing that
was really cool just isn't working for
this crowd now is that not going to work
for this crowd universally or is it just
this today this day or is it this whole
generation or is it or is it just me you
know is it my thing and you can't do
that nearly as effectively you can't do
it and the extent to which you know
this is becoming ever more remote to us
because it's been a long time since we
were in the classroom but
the extent to which as you were
lecturing or whatever equivalent of that
you were doing you looked around the
room and you saw let's say you're
teaching alone 25 or so people that you
knew really really well not just their
names not just the basics of where they
came from but knew a lot about their
background their their
style of comprehension their blind spots
and you're talking and you can see
comprehension dawning right it dawns in
the eyes and when it fails to dawn you
know your point didn't land right and so
that dynamic is so important to a really
good teaching environment and it is so
broken by
even zoom
yeah right even zoom breaks it
now there is um
it may well not happen but we've
just heard glimmers of possibility that
we might end up finding our
way in a classroom just for a brief time
next summer again a classroom or another
educational environment um
and it's intriguing precisely because
it's becoming so remote um that um
that the value of of educating
undergraduates or you know anyone with
with capacity i mean i just think that
educating very small children is is a
different kind of thing yeah um but you
know call it sort of high schoolers
through adults um
is is so much in the interaction and as
you said it's it's fading you know for
me it's been
almost five years you know you because i
was on sabbatical the last two thirds of
the year that um that evergreen blew up
on us
and uh that's just a that's just a lot
of time that's elapsed at this point um
to not update our model to not update um
to not have any new
people and their experiences and their
ways of interacting in our heads um and
yeah
maybe that's it
yeah
there's something else which i think at
some point we need to talk about i'll
just put a little
uh stub here that we can return to
there was also a way in which inevitably
if you were the sort of professor who
really cared about students and you know
as you've pointed out many times there
were lots of professors who didn't even
learn the names of their students and in
this environment that was that was
educational malpractice to be certain
but if you were the kind of person who
understood
that knowing them was key to teaching
them well then it was inevitable
that you would
care about
the
position in life their
trials and tribulations
mattered
and
i think the point is you just as you
care about your friends and it's not you
know it's not just about those things on
which you know you may be teamed up in
business or whatever right you you end
up caring about people and the extent to
which
you know you you become yes it's an
asymmetrical kind of friendship but you
become friends with these students and
some of them become unasymmetrical after
yeah when they graduate and think the
professional relationship is over but
um
yeah it's completely amazing and also um
really
almost entirely all-encompassing yeah
and uh
you know there's a lot there's a lot to
say here but
i loved doing the work i was surprised
to to love learning how to be an
educator
as much as i as i did and of course we
did develop a lot of ideas um while
doing it and so you know this book is is
a piece of that
that framework that we were
developing but um
but choosing to basically throw all in
to the education part of of higher ed
and to do so in which relationships with
the students and knowing something about
them was absolutely imperative like i
could not
the idea of standing up in front of
people who were strangers to me week
after week was completely intolerable i
i would not have done the work i would
have refused it
um but that did mean that basically that
you know that
that and the ideas that we're being
generated in the classroom and then you
know our family was very much the full
the full thing and so
you know the sabbatical that i had the
last two quarters of evergreen was
effectively me
saying okay i know that i wanted to
write this
this turns out as a science fiction
novel for a very long time
and
i think i can do it if i'm not also
teaching but i don't know because
because everyone had a terrible you know
they didn't pay very well and they
didn't have a very good sabbatical
program so after you know 14 years i
finally got two quarters of sabbatical
um
and yeah sure enough i did it i did it
really quickly i was like okay yes that
is also yes it's one off it's an n of
one but it was i i predicted in advance
the thing that is um that is preventing
you know sort of productivity in the in
the outside world outside of the
classrooms and the field settings is in
part the really heavy investment with
the the the community that is being
built that we are building in these
classrooms and yeah they were 25 if it
was one of us teaching 50 if it was two
of us slightly lower if we were studying
abroad but um
you know you really really just came to
know people so so so well and you know
the the metaphor at evergreen
mostly was about faculty but i certainly
you know felt felt a sense of this um
with the whole community was like you
know you're courting and then you decide
to come together and there's sort of a
marriage and then at the end when the
thing dissolves it's it's a divorce and
it doesn't have to be an ugly divorce
but it'll never come back together again
no no no
you're right that there's something
familial about it i never once felt that
the end of a program was divorce-like
and i think part of but it was an ending
yeah it was an ending but i think the
problems and divorces are
just ends that aren't yeah but
for us
we had a community of people who bounced
around between our programs they took
them when we taught together
and so
i don't i think the thing is it's
obviously a formal ending to the moment
when you're showing up in the class at
the right time of day and delivering
some content and with those people you
know it
there was a repeated sense and you know
everyone who's taught knows this a
little bit but there was just there was
a much deeper sense of community that
was created with every single program a
hundred percent with a four credit class
but you know i used to say that uh
you knew a program was working when
it spilled over outside of class you
know when students would hold parties
and they would be talking about what
they were learning in class and their
you know friends who weren't in those
classes were like wait what is this
right yeah at the point that it was
self-catalyzing and the fact that class
ended for the day didn't mean anything
to anyone because they were really
deeply involved in it that same thing
happens at the ends of the at the ends
of the term or the ends of the the
course
and so anyway you know and that
community largely still exists there are
many students you know who are important
to us who were present in our classes at
different times who are sort of
connected through us to each other you
know oh yeah i've heard teleview you
know that kind of thing right um so
anyway yeah i don't
everything is said except i don't i
didn't feel like there was anything you
know yes it was an analog to some sort
of yeah i mean that wasn't my language
and i never employed it in in the
classroom but that was the metaphor that
was
that was spread around yeah
um is the unity movement dead
second part of the same question do you
know dave smith libertarian and mises
institute guy in my ses
gotta get creative and grab the
awakening masses before they're tricked
into republicanism
um yeah i don't think the unity moves
answer the second question first do you
know who dave smith is libertarian mises
institute
not off the top of your head no not
immediately i don't think so
um the unity movement is not dead
it is
it is about more than i think people
realize because it was
initially about the unity 2020
proposal which was quite narrow
but the world keeps telling us that it
is necessary
right that's the point nothing is
functioning it hasn't gotten better we
elected the the blue team guy and
we can see where we are
so
the answer is
we are still in the same predicament
that caused us to do that certain people
who insisted that the adults were back
have now recognized publicly that oops
that didn't turn out to be true so
if uh the orange guy wasn't the answer
and the blue team guy wasn't the answer
then what you've got a new color
we need to stop playing this as if it's
a you know
sport in which you can recognize your
friends by their jersey
and start remembering what it is that
we're trying to accomplish by being a
society and we do need to find the
adults and stop
killing them off in the primaries
that's a radical idea yeah very radical
yeah
um
this seems like a comment rather than a
question
the right is explored territory risks
are known but resource is limited
the left is unexplored territory which
can have unknown treasures but also
unknown dangers and progress is fine
until it progresses us off a cliff
that's pretty good yeah
um
another comment on another comment is
the last one from a regular contributor
here
time is relative to the proximity of
gravitational forces and psychologically
its passing is relative to the gravity
of the situation
[Music]
i like these kinds of metaphors i like
this very much both of these
yeah
both of these
and that is an excellent gravitational
lens
what is the evolutionary advantage of
marking time i.e birthdays anniversaries
of good and bad events like 911. why
does this and does it help us
who why do this and does it help us get
our genes into the future
this is a fascinating question yep um
you want to take it on first sure yeah i
uh a
i think there's certain things that we
mark time and it very clearly has
something to do with processes that
require us to do this i'm thinking
you know the uh most salient example
for me would be the um
jewish tradition
of waiting a year to put a headstone on
a grave right burying a person quickly
and returning in a year to put the
headstone and it seems to me that this
fits actually very well with the natural
progress of grief
that there is
a one-year process there's something
about being through a whole cycle
without someone
that uh
you know
completes a part of that process
and that reminds me of the return
in madagascar the turning of the bones
ceremonies
in which
it's different for
i think all of the 17 ish tribes in
madagascar do it although certainly it's
more than one and when exactly the
retroman happens relative to the harvest
is different in different places but in
among the bets of masarika which is the
one to which i was invited it's around
harvest time
if memory serves and so it is an annual
event when um there is a day when the
bones of the ancestors are um
disinterred are brought back up and
those who are
more freshly dead
um uh if they have decayed entirely such
that it's just bones are
they're the body boxes that they were in
effectively coffins um their bones are
cleaned they're given new shrouds and
they're put into bone boxes
and if they were
if they were already in bone boxes um
then they are simply brought up and then
while they are up above ground
there is a ceremony in which the elder
of the village the currently living
elder of the village speaks to both the
living and the dead about what has
transpired in the last in the last year
and
in that case
you are you're speaking to not just
those who have died in the last year and
it's not an anniversary of their death
but it's at the same moment every year
you as the living will be reminded of
those who have come before and the
wisdom of the ancestors yes it's not i
think it's not just the wisdom of the
ancestors and in this case um there is
something
that is not well described i think
anywhere
where
um
one is related through someone else
right so
um like in-laws yes but i think the the
point is um
i i don't want to explore it too fully
but you and i are related to each other
through our children right it's a blood
relationship even though it's not a
blood relationship diatically um
and there is also something then so the
addition of our children to our
lineage
uh to what was to what is now uh
is now our
that same process is mirrored by the
absence of somebody through whom you
were connected right
and so
in
i guess my point would be there is a
tendency if you are
um
treating your cousin
well
because you don't want to displease your
aunt
or your aunt i don't think ants care
very much about this sort of thing but
your aunt
they love their sisters
yes they do let's say you're treating
your cousin well because you love your
aunt and it displeases her when you
fight or something like that and then
she dies
right suddenly your
uh the behavioral restrictions are
removed are removed unless you're going
to have to explain it to her every year
yeah right yeah and here's what happened
this year yeah right we're at each other
again exactly and so the thing is you
don't want to especially you know the
way it's set up it's one of these
beautiful things you know like uh you
know catholics and confession it's set
up in order to disincentivize the bad
behavior in this case not only are you
gonna have to face your aunt again and
tell her that you've started [ __ ] up
now that she's gone
but um you're gonna have to do it it
will be recounted in front of others
right and so the point is what this
tends to do is stabilize our view of
each other so that the loss of an
individual which is unpredictable and
negative isn't so uh such a violent
disruption of the
you know the inter
workings of the the tribe
yeah
yeah
uh
so i guess there's also uh this is a
little different but we talk in the book
a fair a bit about rites of passage yeah
and so marking time that is meaningful
developmentally
um even if it's not all that meaningful
sort of astronomically right so you know
different traditions you might come of
age at 13 and the jewish tradition or 15
in the mexican tradition or you know at
different ages and in some cases um it's
not determined by age but sort of like
oh there's a cohort ready and that
cohort of men who are ready to become
you know boys who are ready to become
men or girls who already become women
might have an age range of 13 to 16 or
something um
that those those are effectively marking
um
marking achievement via time rather than
marking time explicitly yeah yeah
they're different and actually this is a
perfect analog to the
little disagreement we had at the
beginning of the main podcast because
both kind of i don't remember it we were
talking about laboratory time oh yeah
versus what i was not
labeling but basically organic time and
i'm not arguing that laboratory time
didn't pre-exist the you know creatures
it exists there's something that we can
go back and look at
but from the point of view of an evolved
creature
you ought to measure time and keep track
of it in whichever way is most useful
and so if you're you know in the far
north latitude and your days are
expanding and contracting with the year
you ought to look at time very
differently well yeah for instance you
expect you might expect if you're a
normally diurnal creature to sleep a lot
more
when the sun is down a lot more and to
be awake a lot more in the summer right
and so in any case the point is there
are two very real kinds of time and as
soon as we started sticking clocks on
the wall
basically one of them eclipses the other
because it's like we'll know what time
is it really yeah you know it's 5 37. i
mean i was talking about this a week or
two ago with regard to speed um or you
know maybe it was just in my natural
selections piece i think i was talking
about it here too but you know that
you know how it is that we understand
speed uh you know when you're on a
bicycle or in a car with the window
stand or convertible you feel the wind
and you feel the cant of the road and
you see how other people are interacting
with you how their cars people are
interacting with you and
all of that is how you understand how
fast you're going the noise of the row
of the tires on the road depending on
what the surface is or you can look at
the speedometer
right and the speedometer is the thing
that the cop is going to be asking you
for when he pulls you over he's not
going to be asking you for how your hair
felt and you know what you were hearing
in terms of the crunch of the tires
but you actually have a much more
embodied sense of speed
with that first way of knowing and so
you know this is just the temporal
equivalent of that spatial thing like
okay there are multiple ways at least
two yeah ways of knowing sort of at a
visceral fully embodied level space you
know how your physical presence in space
and also in time and there's the ways
that we have come to measure these
things and we have largely replaced
our understanding um of those earlier
more complete understandings of space
and time with the newer technological
simpler less nuanced more reductionist
measures yeah it's like it's adjusted
for relevance
right
let me give you an example
if you are
driving down the road in your car at 25
miles an hour right maybe you're going
25 miles an hour because the guy in
front of you is going 25 miles an hour
and it's a 30 mile an hour zone and
you're feeling impatient about the way
you are crawling down the road right
we've all been there on the other hand
if you're on your bike at 25 miles an
hour right it's pretty exciting um and
so at some level it should be exciting
because it's actually perilous yeah
right 25 miles an hour is enough for you
to make an error that matters you got to
be fully aware of what you're doing the
wind is rushing by your ears right it's
it's a very different phenomenon to
compare the two is 25 miles an hour fast
yeah yes on a bike no in a car and the
point is you can have a speedometer on
both right but they're not comparable
speeds right that's right so yeah i i
think this is this is right
yeah
cool
as a federal employee i'm concerned with
biden's latest vaccine mandate
curious on your thoughts of threatening
people with joblessness myself included
to push a vaccine
we have arrived somewhere incredibly
dangerous because at the very least um
the right to coerce people and heather
and i may differ a little bit on this
but i i believe there is a right to
coerce people in the interest of public
health but i do not believe we have come
anywhere near the burden of
responsibility necessary before you even
contemplate coercing people in this way
right we for example
have not made people
safe from the corrupting influence of
corporations that
have a financial stake in whether we are
or are not
compelled
and so the point is until you're made
safe from the forces that might cause
this to be used in an illegitimate way
you don't get the right to coerce and
so anyway yes uh in in a different world
there might be a legitimate use of this
but wow is the standard high
before you reach the the place where you
have a right to contemplate such things
and we just haven't met it exactly um
i was going to try to find
um because we weren't going to talk
about this
i didn't queue it up and i can't find it
but um
the guardian of all places
had a
article this morning
um
that was referring to research that is
still not
peer-reviewed and of course the research
itself does some hedging because that is
what we're obliged to do now
um but the guardian reports on some new
research in a pre-print oh maybe that's
where it is
uh
oh here's the here's the actual
pre-print this isn't the guardian
article
um
sars kobe 2 mrna vaccination associated
myocarditis and children ages 12 to 17 a
stratified national database analysis
the conclusion of this research which
the guardian actually reports on is they
find that for boys between the ages of
12 to 17 the risks of the vaccine
outweigh the risks of coping
there's lots we don't know there's ways
they could be wrong but this is what
this research finds yeah and and the
guardian actually reports that
now the guardian is about as far
left
yeah i was like pseudo left something
whatever this is now blue team yeah but
they're in the uk so labor team
something
um
i get that right yeah yeah um
as as is out there and
you know given these sorts of results
that even some of the most blue team
woke journalistic outfits are reporting
the idea of of
mandates when we clearly do not
do not understand the risks and there is
research showing that at least for some
populations
um the risks outweigh the benefits
is um
isn't insane so you move yeah now
obviously there's no level of caution
that is enough for
emerging research like that but
we have talked extensively about the
question
you know why is it that we have not
publicly engaged the
age stratified risk profile so that we
can ask the question are we vaccinating
young people to protect old people and
does a rational society do that right
right um
yes
i mean obviously we do
obviously we would be vaccinating young
people to protect old people but if it
is not justified with respect to the
young people that we are vaccinating if
they are facing
uh substantial risks and the benefit is
recovered in the protection of the old
and infirm i would argue that that is
not a decent thing to do that one thing
that all
societies that are long-lived are going
to agree on is that the protection of
the young is their obligation yes right
we do not we do not rob the young of
health in order to award it to the old
that's right
um
my body my joyce slogan for no jab now
versus pro-choice in the past
thoughts so that's sort of a
telegraphically
posed question but um
i think i was never a fan of my body my
choice yeah as a slogan and and i've
said this places um it never it it it's
it's a libertarian conclusion and um
i think in an actual functioning society
that is honoring its commitments to its
citizens
has
has the right to expect some things in
return and i'm not saying that i know
where those boundaries are and i am
actively um and you know very much
pro-choice
um
but not because my body my choice yeah
it's not not not for that reason and so
i don't for me my body my choice um and
especially how it's being grabbed by
some people who are using it cynically
who never would have used it
um on the right for for no jab um i mean
there's there is something there there's
something in it that i think is
true but like but
but there's something about the framing
that doesn't quite work yeah i've always
disliked it and the reason is this we
know it can't be a very good formulation
because you can make exactly the same
argument for
your house
my house my choice does that mean you
can beat your kids it sure doesn't right
and so the point is if the fact that
it's your thing doesn't mean
that logically you have a right to do
whatever you want there yeah but i mean
there's the individual is a real thing
right
uh only sort of the boundaries are
fuzzier than we like to admit
um certainly you know at the ends and
right at the end points temporally
the boundaries are fuzzier and maybe
even spatially if you know using sort of
dawkins extended phenotype
idea
or you know other things the fact is we
now know that we are temporary can
custodians of our genomes and that they
are modified and that our bad behavior
actually has consequences for people we
will never meet downstream of us for
example genetically how dare you right
epigenetically
epigenetically how dare you now that's a
shirt
but um yeah so there are those things
and also
when we've been incredibly clear about
this throughout the pandemic there's
also the fact that being reckless about
contagious disease does result in harms
that come to people who had no choice in
the matter so the point is
the formulation doesn't add up
but what has to be done
is we have to understand what would be
required to trigger the conclusion of
that formulation in this case or to fail
to trigger it and so
that that you know the obligations from
society from from government have not
been met right they have not they have
not been met and so the point i think i
think to the extent
that there's something valid in this
idea the idea is look
until you have done everything necessary
that you overcome all of the real and
substantial objections right
then we have to default to this other
thing which is you don't get to force me
yeah right you get to force me
when you have met the obligations that
you must in order that this actually is
not only in our collective interest but
it's in my interest i may be taking a
risk but that risk is worth taking right
and so
uh
having not met that this is sort of the
fallback position right absent absent
meeting the threshold that society would
have to meet its side of the contract
there is no contract and therefore
it would be my choice
yes good if you're not going to protect
me from economic corruption that would
affect the decision making and the data
analysis on this point then it would
have to be my choice to say well then
i'm not going to participate
yep
what evolutionary pressure would our
dramatic change in behavior like masks
and distancing etc have on existing
pathogens like flu and others
very interesting question yeah always
wondered and in fact uh years ago when
we were teaching at evergreen i always
wanted to run a class in which we masked
over the course of the winter to see you
did talk about this i sure did you sure
did i wanted to know whether it was
going to affect the rate at which people
contracted uh respiratory pathogens
um and we were going to compare to
another class or even just do it well
that would have been real tough to pull
off but i was sorry but i feel like
just even like the week the first week
of class after everyone has returned
from where everyone has returned from
yeah
um
could
could reduce i mean everyone with kids
has had this experience when you go back
to school if your kids go to daycare and
if you're a professor in the classroom
and so for us you know every fall like
okay our kids are back in school and
we're back in school and like we're
gonna get sick
um so yeah having you know if you know
to that degree that the masks are
effective against respiratory viruses um
having a masking period that is short
right after
right as populations are coming
populations coming back together from a
lot of disparate places uh might
actually reduce a lot of illness
i'm not sure if i
said this on an early livestream
we certainly discussed it and i don't i
just don't know if it came up uh when we
were on but
i
wanted to see an initiative
where
we started actively tracking the
pathogens that circulate every year
and learning to control them that is to
say figuring out the things that we
figured out about covid early on about
how it transmits right whether it's
transmission whether it's all right
right so if you did that for all of the
things that don't matter that much the
little cold viruses that we encounter
and you just got good at figuring out
okay here's how this pathogen that
spread around the world or spread around
this community but missed that community
right
i missed that community right yeah
here's and then think of all the
knowledge that you would gain and if you
if we just got good at you know it's
difficult to stamp out a cold virus but
it might not be difficult to control it
if you understood how it was passing
around yeah and the fact is the costs
that come to us from all these little
things that circulate are not tiny not
only do they you know wreck a week of
your life at a time or more
but they have health consequences right
i'm convinced that the destruction that
comes from these things you feel like oh
i recovered therefore all i lost was
that weak but no they impacted tissues
in your body you're spending some of
your lifetime health fending off each
one of these things so to the extent
that we can recover a bunch of time and
a lot of health by simply getting better
at fending these things off we would
train ourselves so the next time some
really bad thing emerged we would know a
lot right rather than starting from
square one i mean it would it would
require good data right it would require
a lot of good data i remember maybe a
year ago so well into the covered
pandemic um pre-vaccines
um
i was in some health building and uh
some medical building and i got into an
elevator
or a couple women got into an elevator
after me and this was before all the
signs are up on all the elevators some
somehow even
though it's hard to imagine now right
like we're supposed to only be in these
little boxes with our own people or
something
um but um these two women got in after
me
and i did what i've actually in the long
habit of doing especially in a place
where there are sick people and i press
the button with my elbow um and if i
can't i'll press it with my you know
just i will not yeah a knuckle or
something
um and one of them you know we're all
wearing masks and one of them just
starts beaming at me and she says i'm a
nurse i've been doing that forever and
people just laugh at me i said well it's
not going to stop covid you know right
and she's i know like it turns out it's
not for covid but you know think of all
the things it is good for and it just
started me thinking like i s there are
things that transfer by there are
pathogens that transfer via phonics and
we are much more likely to do this than
this right like you're much more likely
to put your your finger on your mouth or
your face or eat and touch your food
right but not your knuckles and
certainly not your elbow um but there's
also times i'm like okay
um it's actually much easier for me to
do this to you know to touch something
with my hand how
how out of the way should i be going to
do this i'd really actually like to have
the data right well and we just don't
have it like like certainly it's in our
collective interest to know well this is
this is what i was advocating but it
would require something like an
institute and you would have to immunize
that institute from the corruption that
would otherwise destroy the project and
turn it into a pet project of something
that can make a profit from it
i would also point out that probably
even though the touching of the buttons
is not likely to control covet directly
there's also a lot to be said about what
effect does it have that you've come
down with something else for your
vulnerability now you're compromised yep
right so
anyway yes there's a whole
you know obviously this is what
epidemiology is about but i can't say
that i'm very impressed with what we the
public know about how to avoid diseases
that circulate all the time so oh
absolutely and so i mean the original
question
like does just like the hygiene hygiene
hypothesis which is well known and we
also talk about in the health or
medicine chapter of the book
suggests that actually eradicating all
pathogens from your environment is
likely going to make you sicker
long-term for a number of reasons
there is reason to think that
providing your immune system no
um no exposure to things um for a fairly
long time uh will render it hyper
responsive at the point that it does
come into contact uh this may be true
i'm not totally convinced that this
makes sense but it may well be true and
i'm just behind the times on this one
no i'm not i think i think we don't know
i think it sounds plausible to me and
i'm not that's the problem yes it sounds
plausible but i'm not sure that it's a
proper announcement i don't think you're
not behind the times i think we don't
know yeah okay um i did want to point
this out though i noticed when we were
in texas right texas has a very
different
sense about it with respect to
compliance different culture than
portland oregon you don't say right but
here's what i noticed
first of all let's just say the evidence
on the effectiveness of cloth masks is
pretty poor yeah right
it's too bad but it's hard to
demonstrate the effectiveness of these
things but that said
here's the missed opportunity that i saw
right we did not have a vehicle we
didn't rent a vehicle
so we were taking
uber
to go from place to place
uber requires you to click i have a mask
and i will wear it before it will
confirm your ride okay yep so far so
good
but the driver arrives
in general just wasn't true every time
but in general the driver is not wearing
a mask until you get into the vehicle so
if they do work
they have already filled the vehicle
with these particles and that that's two
different things right if the masks work
it only started working after the point
that the person
if they were sick had already filled the
vehicle with whatever viral particles
they might have and here's the
opportunity right it it is um september
here in the pacific northwest
also into september everywhere right yes
so here's my point yep the right thing
to do if you're really trying to control
this pathogen
the right thing to do for an uber driver
as they pull up
right for the half a block before they
get to you is to open every window to
air out the vehicle
right and then
if they then put on their mask and you
have your mask getting in and masks have
some value but even if you didn't the
point is they will have reduced the
concentration of whatever they're
exhaling absolutely and so in some sense
this feels you know security theater
with the tsa where you know you're doing
all kinds of absurd things that probably
don't have anything yeah shoes off
liquids out okay right yeah um we also
now we have epidemiology theater right
and the point is and how
people are behaving as if controlling
the virus is a matter of putting in the
effort right rather than actually doing
something that's coherent right
coherent very much so right and we have
rules and we know that rules can make
you safe right therefore if while the
people who want you to follow the rules
are watching
if you follow the rules then then you
too will be safe right but i you know i
didn't see a single driver air out there
right vehicle i didn't see anybody i
mean it was hot yeah but we took a took
a couple overs at night when it wasn't
that hot right and rolling down the
windows in that case i mean you know
getting in an uber is i think it's the
most dangerous thing we do
epidemiologically in this pandemic well
that or a
elevator in a crowded building yeah yeah
small sport you know or or a small
public bathroom like these these are the
well here's the thing about the uber is
the last person in the uber or the
driver has an awful lot of time to
saturate that very tiny volume yeah
right the elevator if somebody gets in
and gets out you know five floors away
even if they're sick and exhaling the
stuff they may not saturate it
same thing if they go into a bathroom
briefly so whereas the uber has the car
has the capacity to totally refresh the
air or almost actually yeah that's yeah
the the difference between it's the
worst environment if you do nothing and
it's a decent environment if you do a
lot yeah so and that lot really takes
very little like you you'll lose a
little efficiency if it is hot out you
got the ac running you're going to lose
some efficiency you get lower gas
mileage but
um potentially a
potentially a pretty big uptick in in
health i would think i absolutely think
i absolutely think so and my guess is
that this
if we had a good model of all of these
viruses right even the common cold the
point is boundary layers applies to all
of them right right and density the
density dependence thing applies to
probably all of them i don't know but
like a lot of them at any rate yeah so
the question is
why do we humans not walk around with a
better model of um cars are unnaturally
concentrating of pathogens by virtue of
their air tightness their small volume
and the long period of time you may be
in them ding ding ding right yeah and
here's your control mechanism at least
when it's not really cold i mean even
when it's really cold you can open the
windows for you know a minute yeah right
how much air do you trade out in a
minute a lot
um so anyway we're really missing the
mark here's a more just like vitamin d
this is more really low hanging fruit
and how many people will die because we
never had a discussion about how to make
cars safer yeah yep
wow
um just bought your book via amazon
australia yippee sanity and grace coming
yeah i didn't know that it was
translated into australia
yeah you do now i do
i'm not sure about this question i'm
going to ask it and see if you
see what you do with it
would simulated realities be a form of
fourth frontier given that they aren't
subject to resource limits beyond what's
needed for processing power
um i think you're on to something but i
would like to change it slightly so
to the extent
that what one needs to do is provide a
coherent a resource coherent
way of being
that is to say something that doesn't
violate any uh
rules of you know physical rules
equilibrium
limits
but that provides
the sensory impression of growth the
point is the sensory impression could
come from just about anywhere and
that means there is some possibility
that some fraction of the sensory issue
could be addressed this way now what my
concern would be especially if you start
thinking that this is liable to be an
important tool in the toolkit is that
creating the impression that you're
doing better than you are that the
people who govern you are better than
they are fairer than they are more
decent or whatever is the problem right
and so
you would have to have a system
that was honorable in deploying
something of this nature because
otherwise it is so ripe for abuse that
that that is effectively inevitable
yeah
does life survive best with periods of
expansion and contraction i.e robust
growth
what does life survive best with periods
of expansion and contraction
um maybe put aside the i.e robust growth
and i would say that at looking for a
simple rubric for that condition under
which life survives best is the wrong
approach right there will be some you
know
that life that has evolved with uh
contracting and expanding resource space
will be
adapted to such a thing and
and vice versa
you yeah
i think i think we're missing some
parameters here there's certainly it is
certainly true that a contraction
will cause
an increase in
uh
anti-fragility
right in other words if you keep editing
back the population what is left over
will have the characteristics that don't
get edited out and so this is how
selection works
but um those characteristics in
if life then evens out you don't have
expansion contraction uh will be a cost
um not born by those who don't have it
who will therefore be able to use their
resources for something else
so i mean i i think at looking for a
single stable solution is is the error
here
yeah i mean i i feel like we're talking
past one yeah i'm not convinced i
understand
uh the question really
you know what what is being maximized
the
durability of the life in question the
use of resources what is it
well but i mean i guess i'm
i feel like this is a question that is
ripe for an analysis of a discussion of
trade-offs right that um
does you know why do asexual organisms
persist
even though sexual reproduction uh
evolved
one to two billion years ago and
maybe once um in a lineage where sexual
reproduction evolved um you have had
persistent asexuality um recur
um
there
you can't say therefore that you know
sexual reproduction is just the best
thing there are conditions in which asex
reproduction is effective and there are
conditions in which sexual reproduction
is effective and so it's the conditions
that render the thing better or worse
and so you know the question seems to me
to presume a sort of
uh
a best state absent context and this is
a you know pretty pretty standard
misunderstanding of evolutionary
thinking but a really a kind of a dire
one it's exactly the sort of error that
leads to things like social darwinism
and eugenics and such right the idea
that um you know whatever whatever is on
top right now therefore needed to be on
top for good reason and therefore should
be on top forever after it's like no all
of these things are context dependent
and also what do you mean by on top
anyway yeah so maybe the problem in the
question is the word life
that it's
the most general case
okay
now in this case i'm not sure i
understand the question so let's see if
if you do
i sense that i will
i hope you do
what encouraging non-reproductive
behavior in those outside your gene pool
fit with your thoughts with your
thoughts on an evolutionary basis for
opportunity hoarding and redistribution
through genocide
oh are people favored to induce others
into
evolutionarily
self-defeating strategies yes including
non-reproduction yes
undoubtedly and in fact
we see you know one of our worst fears
of course is
that
populations will sterilize other
population i mean we've seen this with
the chinese and the uyghurs
yeah right and so the idea that
sterilization
brings to mind a physiological
intervention but it doesn't have to be
that it could be the disrupting of the
coherent behavior of a population that
would result in such things yes yeah
although i mean i think sort of famously
you know neither you nor i are the first
to to raise this question but there is
there is the apparent
uh paradox in
many men um appearing to be very
homophobic when uh at least at least
this used to be the case um which would
you know if if you're in a say you're in
a college situation yeah um wouldn't
having more gay men around mean that
there's more straight women left for you
yeah
it is a paradox except that
uh one imagines that the primary impact
of that kind of culture is to
um
punish this behavior within one's own
lineage
i've never seen it attempted to be
teased apart at an empirical yeah yeah
okay when did we start zach
uh
three and a half billion years ago what
did you say zach exactly
okay
i was given the lineage level answer
right you were no that's just like you
um okay so
let's see let's do one or two more uh
will you ever speak to jonathan pajot
again perhaps symbolism of covid and 666
um i don't know what
those last two things are but of course
i like jonathan i i talk to him again
yeah um
okay there's a couple here i just don't
know the answers but i'll ask um okay i
see the one that will end on but i'll
ask one more here
that you may or may not know the answer
to i do not in the save the world
podcast dr malone said that pfizer had
submitted a new biodistribution data
package any updates what happened
thanks i don't know yeah i don't know
yeah
okay final question
any advice on how to maintain your
mental health in such concerning times
go outside eat good food
that's a big part of it it's not
it might be sufficient
oh that would be great um but you'll
follow all of those things to sort of
their natural conclusions and also
generalize from them
yeah i'll go i'll go one step further
great um
you absolutely positively 100
need at least one person that you can be
completely open with about your fears
your hopes your expectations
your understanding you need that person
it's not optional and the problem is we
have lived through a long period of time
in which it was more or less optional
you were better off with it but things
weren't of in nature that it was
required to even keep your sanity one
week to the next but it has become
necessary and
so what i would say is
we we have sold people to create though
if you don't have it right but the point
is where it fits in your priority scheme
of what matters
is top level and
i would just say
we have been sold a bill of goods on
multiple fronts that
leads us to believe that life is about
pleasure and therefore
you should do that which
increases your pleasure rather than
understanding that pleasure is a means
to an end it is supposed to direct you
towards things that are good it has now
been hijacked to direct you towards
things that are bad that doesn't mean
that every bit of pleasure is that way
but it means an awful lot
of what you can source in the market
that provides you pleasure is actually a
transfer of well-being from you to
whoever is selling the goddamn thing so
the point is
your relationship
right your primary relationship and your
other relationships are a key to your
functionality to your ability to even
think straight in this stupid era so
the point is do they frustrate you
sure right but do they make you stronger
and healthier and clearer of mind and
better able to steer out of the way of
danger absolutely and if they please you
that's great and if they don't please
you figure out how to make them please
you in some way but the point is it's a
functional it's a functional interaction
with the universe it's not you pleasure
is supposed to be
the indicator that it's working not
the reason for the interaction and i
just think
the difference between people who have
somebody else that they can uh can talk
to openly
and those who are isolated is all the
difference in the world in this kind of
crisis and that's that's the universe's
way of telling us how important this
stuff is
that's wonderful um and i do think that
the maybe the penultimate point you made
is is crucial so i'll just repeat it so
that it doesn't get buried the idea that
um
the the pleasure you get from such an
interaction
is uh not the goal it is the indicator
that um the thing that is presumably the
goal is functioning
and we make this mistake we conflate
those two things in all domains we do
and in fact very frequently you'll find
a pair of things that have some
relationship some people will think they
are synonyms but they are not so for
example
um happiness
is a fool's errand hey zach
um thank you happiness he's a fool's
errand right if you pursue happiness you
will very often pay a very high price to
get it that is not justified by what you
get if you pursue
satisfaction
right
you end up
happy some fraction of the time but the
nature of happiness is so thin
that um
you know it should not take over your
your priority scheme and
uh
recognizing these distinctions
will do a lot to get you to sort out
your life and it will not make you
happier but it will make you more
satisfied almost certainly
all right
we'll be back next week at which point
our book will have been published and
uh see how that caterpillar does then
yeah we'll see about that caterpillar
all right um
uh share share this if you like it and
uh share the first hour hour and a half
whatever it was
and um
maybe i won't i don't i don't have it in
me right now i'm not going to go through
all the other stuff
yeah yeah so um
get outside
treat
the ones you love with with love and
care and respect
eat good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you